[Musica]
grazie mille di essere qui a varese
countdown l'iniziativa insomma di teatro
male per dare vita a scambi e
conversazioni è in grado di accelerare
soluzioni per la crisi climatica
trasformando le idee in azioni
luca peraltro qualche giorno fa ha
tenuto il suo primo texture cat dix
milano e oggi è qui anche per respirare
insomma i nostri artisti con il suo
lavoro e i suoi spunti parliamo
ovviamente di fotografia e del ruolo
insomma che ha nel raccontare in modo
efficace le soluzioni alla crisi
climatica e partirei forse da degli
ultimi premi world che hai vinto il like
a oskar barnack award che è un premio
che nasce nel
1979 preso appunti mi sono studiato e
celebrate la fotografia quella in grado
di esprimere no la relazione tra essere
umano e ambiente
lo vinci nel 2020 con un progetto che è
ciccio destatis e il premio ne parla
così sul sito e poi ti chiedono
ovviamente di
spiegarci un pochettino il perché hai
fatto questo progetto e che cosa in che
cosa consiste
un progetto di lungo respiro che ha
l'obiettivo specifico di esplorare le
nuove modalità di sopravvivenza sul
pianeta terra da parte dell'essere umano
luca locatelli dice l'award
mette in discussione il nostro concetto
di bisogno di crescita economica
permanente e usa il suo progetto per
dare vita a un intenso dibattito sulla
nostra relazione con la natura e la
tecnologia e quindi per la mia prima
domanda per te è questa che cosa ti ha
spinto a intraprendere un progetto di
questo tipo e che cos'è shooter studies
e perché per te è importante
allora tutto è iniziato
moltissimi anni fa in amazzonia
come attivista giovane attivista che che
s'è innamorato fondamentalmente la
protezione ambientale quindi
di tutto ciò che riguarda il valore che
abbiamo sul pianeta la vita da difendere
no
fino a quando in un percorso in cui poi
è arrivata la fotografia
veramente capito a un certo punto che
noi no
del primo mondo cosiddetto ce l'abbiamo
sempre un po il diritto di dire agli
altri cosa dobbiamo fare no e quindi
evidenziamo sempre un po il problema
degli altri ma poi alla fine siamo un po
noi che partecipiamo all'equazione
climatica in maniera così devastante e
grazie anche a un background che ho mio
sulla tecnologia io facevo l'informatico
prima di fare il fotografo
a un certo punto ho cominciato a
interrogarmi su quelle che potevano
essere
le azioni che noi stavamo facendo per
contrastare questo problema e
devo dire che non era non era un gran
all'inizio ho fatto veramente fatica
perché la crisi climatica
non era presente nei media cioè non se
ne parlava in nessun modo però ho
cominciato a scoprire alcuni primi
esempi virtuosi di come
noi potevamo innanzitutto fare qualcosa
e a quel punto ho iniziato un percorso
che poi ha preso il nome di appunto
ufficio studies che ha semplicemente un
esplorazione in giro per il mondo di
quelle che sono le soluzioni più più
promettenti che abbiamo per affrontarla
realmente questa crisi climatica perché
trovo fondamentalmente
fondamentale anche
informare
diciamo informare su tutti i canali
possibili immaginabili le persone di
quelle che possono essere
realmente le soluzioni marina poter
ricostruire anche un immaginario del
futuro perché appunto le nuove
generazioni crescono ormai in un momento
storico in cui non li ha più concesso di
sognare immaginare il futuro mentre noi
quando siamo cresciuti alla mia
generazione volevamo fare gli astronauti
volevamo fare
tante cose potevamo immaginarci quello
che sarebbe successo se noi avessimo ha
conseguito i nostri obiettivi
e qui nel mio lavoro cerca di di
ricostruire questa questione hanno
spezzato
che si chiama speranza e cercare di
immaginare un futuro che sicuramente
sarà diverso perché non possiamo pensare
di tornare indietro ma che comunque è un
futuro possibile
grazie
oggi per noi ha importato una selezione
di immagini
di storie dietro assolutamente una
storia
assolutamente loro intanto
ok
perché poi appunto tutte queste cose non
si parla si vede spesso anche
televisione le soluzioni e le soluzioni
ma cosa sono se soluzioni cioè che che
luca anno no cosa si vedrà nel futuro
come ce lo immaginiamo il mondo nel
futuro e quindi io vi ho portato la
serie di immagini che cercano di fare
questo
io sono fotografo documentarista quindi
a differenza vostra come artisti diciamo
che avete più libertà di movimento
io
osservo il presente quindi non tocca
minimamente il
presente ciò che ho davanti
e quindi documento il presente per
cercare di scatenare un futuro per
esempio in questa immagine che voi avete
le mie spalle
sale in islanda un paese altamente
orientato a rapporto un equilibrio uomo
natura in cui abbiamo una sarà
tecnologica che
vive in simbiosi con un vulcano
ovvero usa le ceneri vulcaniche per
crescere i propri prodotti e utilizza
l'energia geotermica per alimentarsi no
per me questa è un'immagine
evocativa
di quella simbiosi che stiamo cercando
nel rapporto uomo natura e tecnologia
perché la tecnologia è sicuramente uno
dei processi che dobbiamo mettere in
campo per poter accelerare queste azioni
qui invece siamo di fronte all'uomo che
insieme ad altri mille uomini
da oltre trent'anni smontano a pezzi una
centrale nucleare nel nord est della
germania vanno in giro in questi
sotterranei a cercare superfici
radioattive metalli e così li ricercano
di pulire
questa questa questa centrale che dava
pensata in energia a tutta berlino est
quindi anche per cercare di recuperare i
metalli di questa centrale in un
processo di circolarità economica
ed è un simbolo del pd di cosa succede
quando quando sbagliavo c'è poi quello
che è il casino che poi ci portiamo
dietro negli errori che facciamo
sempre all'interno di questa storia che
io ho fatto in germania sulla
transizione energetica tedesca perché la
germania un programma governativo
che si pone come obiettivo quello di
chiudere 22 centrali nucleari entro il
2022 ok
una centrale nucleare nel nord ovest
della germania
che non era maestra è entrata in
operatività dopo la riunificazione
tedesca è stata trasformata in una in
una giostra fondamentalmente
in un grande parco divertimenti alte a
tema nucleare e quella che era la torre
di raffreddamento di questa giustezza
persona formata in una giusta questo è
un po il simbolo
riconosciuto dalla nazione nel loro
immaginario del futuro quando nel 2050
le centrali nucleari o le con mine
diventeranno dei luoghi in cui
divertirsi quasi a prendere per i
fondelli il
passato in un qualche modo
e a proposito di simboli qui ci troviamo
di fronte a uno delle ultime icone
industriale nate sul pianeta che è un
inceneritore a copenaghen che si
chiamava garba che che in realtà si pone
come obiettivo quello di unire i muscoli
industriali che ci piacciano o no sono
quelli che ci fanno a tenere accesi i
computer in questo momento le luci
eccetera eccetera all'ambiente quindi
non emette nessun tipo di emissione è
stato studiato per andare a biomassa e
addirittura
è un luogo di attrazione turistica c'è
una pista da sci a suo sul tetto c'è una
parete d'arrampicata e all'interno
moltissimi eventi sulla consapevolezza
della crisi climatica quindi un 3
d'union estremamente interessate tateo
progettato da uno degli architetti più
importanti che abbiamo sul pianeta
e
sempre nel processo di transizione che
io analizzo con le mie immagini non
possiamo dimenticare l'energia
rinnovabile
no qui dovete sapere che
in europa dove siamo molto più avanti di
altri
continenti del mondo
c'è in atto un piano
gigantesco cioè ci sono uomini in questo
momento nel mar baltico che si alzano la
mattina e vanno a installare foreste di
turbine eoliche per super lì per
sopperire alla chiusura a punto delle
centrali nucleari in germania per
esempio che creano più del 23 per cento
dell'energia del quinto paese più
industrializzato al mondo quindi insomma
non è facile dare energia alla germania
e gli sta succedendo questo e noi non lo
vediamo ok quindi io cerco di rendere
visibile questi processi con immagini
attraenti
così come
possiamo parlare dei processi legati
alle
proteine no proprio io che ho notato la
mia passione sulla sull'ambiente in
amazzonia
non ci potevo credere che l'amazzonia
per la gran parte veniva distrutta dal
fatto che noi dobbiamo creare la soia
ok quindi de fori stiamo creando un
nuovo culture di soia che vengono dati
da mangiare agli animali con cui poi ci
facciamo la carne per gli hamburger c'è
un paradosso
assoluto santa più intelligenti per
arrivare a una soluzione così semplice
no e in questo caso per esempio parliamo
di insetti questa è questo è nel centro
di londra questa questa azienda
coltiva insetti da scarti di cibo locale
e caffè ok e costruisce insetti come
forma di proteina molto efficiente da
dare agli animali ok quindi
un'alternativa vera
all al problema che colpisce ancora oggi
l'amazzonia in maniera così
devastante
e qui entriamo
nella fantascienza nel render no è tutto
vero questa è la casa del contadino del
futuro
in olanda l'olanda è il secondo
esportatore di cibo più grande al mondo
dopo gli stati uniti e da 270 volte più
piccolo per il 60 per cento del suo
territorio dovrebbe esistere
fondamentalmente perché
si allaga è stato ripreso dal mare
conquistato dal mare quindi hanno niente
ok e questo niente gli ha permesso di
ottimizzare tutto ok quindi loro sono
riusciti a costruire per primi dei
sistemi operativi
sull'agricoltura che riescono a
coltivare delle quantità di cibo
decisamente massive con un impatto
ambientale
ridottissimo e questo è quello che
succede c'è questa è la la casa di un
contadino di un modem farmer intorno ai
suoi campi
qui invece ci troviamo in un altro
settore di fortissimo impatto che è il
mondo fashion
il fashion e soprattutto il fast fashion
ha generato in un tremendo impatto
ambientale
parliamo di un 15 20 per cento
sull'equazione climatica
è in realtà
nella mia investigazione ho scoperto che
a prato ok qui in italia
abbiamo un esempio virtuoso
centenario ok di come la spazzatura
tessile si può rigenerare in un'ala
ma la la meccanica sostenibile quindi
loro da centinaia d'anni sanno capace
solo capace di prendere la spazzatura
tessile e reaper sfornarla in materia
prima e lo fanno per i grandi brand
perché oggi ovviamente su stenebo no è
quell etichetta che permette
ai grandi brand della moda ma anche del
fast fashion di vendere alle nuove
generazioni
così come
[Applauso]
[Musica]
dobbiamo riconsiderare
l'importanza della natura e delle
tecnologie naturali quando parlo di
tecnologie naturali parlo proprio della
natura come la miglior tecnologia che
abbiamo da mettere in campo c'è qui per
esempio di fronte a una a un'azienda nel
montana negli stati uniti che ha
inventato questo sistema di ripulire le
acque sporche cittadine attraverso un
bioreattore di alghero ok e non fa con
una capacità impressionante dal punto di
vista qualitativo
quindi molto meglio di processo diciamo
chimici e
con un processo naturale legato alla
fotosintesi clorofilliana abbastanza
semplice e quello che gli ritorna in
cambio è una polvere verde che è lo
scarto che le alghe generano chi vende
alle grandi mode aziende della moda come
bio plastica per farci le suole delle
scarpe ok quindi un esempio dove la
natura
usata intelligentemente salva la natura
ok
dobbiamo dimenticarci della natura
nella sua
concretezza
e capacità
di riso di risolvere il nostro problema
dovete pensare che nell'equazione
climatica
noi abbiamo il cinquanta per cento del
problema viene risolto dalla natura cern
a quello che mi e mettiamo in atmosfera
come co2 viene
praticamente assorbito per il 50 per
cento
da ciò che abbiamo in questo momento a
livello naturale sul pianeta quindi se
noi togliamo
la natura ovviamente sbilanciamo i
calcoli delle soluzioni
sulla crisi climatica e noi pensiamo
sempre all'amazzonia come io per primo
questa è la posidonia io questa foto
l'ho scattata qualche settimana fa in
sardegna
la posidonia che ha quel tipo di d d di
macchianera no su cui noi abbiamo paura
di nuotare quando ci immergiamo nelle
acque della sardegna o nel mediterraneo
in tutto il mondo o che troviamo
spiaggiata e confidiamo come alga ok
in realtà è il virus segreto delle delle
acque cristalline che noi abbiamo in
sardegna delle spiagge rosa e così via e
pensate che la posidonia è capace di
assorbire
20 volte la co2 di una medesima pianta
della stessa dimensione in amazzonia
quindi è fondamentalmente la nostra
amazzone ok e lui ci dobbiamo occupare
di capire di venderci col dire di
crearci una consapevolezza su quelle
tecnologie naturali che sono già a
nostra disposizione e che noi
distruggiamo perché ci buttiamo le
ancore ok quindi
dobbiamo dobbiamo fare fondamentalmente
un gioco tra uomo e tecnologia e
ambiente ma dobbiamo rimettere la natura
al centro dell'equazione prima di tutto
quello che
abbiamo visto
breve
è un riassunto di una visione artistica
ovviamente io di base cerco di prendere
dei re per scientifici complessi e
intima con giornalisti ambientalisti
eccetera
cerco di tradurre quel tipo di
materiale incomprensibile ai più uno in
un'immagine sexy no che che può essere
può creare curiosità a
molte persone e quindi di distribuirla
attraverso il mio lavoro come diceva
anche david con grandi media
internazionali che mi danno accesso a
instagram molto grandi e quindi
fondamentalmente e ha chiaramente a
mostre prestigiose in cui possa essere
coinvolto con il mio lavoro quindi è una
specie di
il mio è diventato un lavoro di
attivismo ok e quindi vengo definito
spesso come un un influenzerà climatico
al positivo e questo è quello che io
fondamentalmente voglio fare
grazie grazie di de luca
[Applauso]
grazie per queste immagini per queste
storie è anche insomma per averci fatto
capire meglio in che modo chi fa
fotografia può avere un ruolo del
generale tutti gli effetti
consapevolezza
l'ultima domanda chi è che ti faccio è
legata agli aspetti concreti loro quando
si sviluppa un progetto di questo tipo
che cosa c'è dietro cosa come si
sostiene e anche in che modo può non
rinnovare il modo in cui l'eco sistema
dei media generale informazione e
comunicazione
è un discorso complesso che cerco di
riassumere velocemente
però diciamo parlando da artisti dire
prima di tutto siate voi stessi ok c'è è
una cosa molto importante quello cioè
quello che c'è dietro è una vera
passione non è una buona idea non è
cavalcare un argomento del momento è una
vera passione che vi guiderà attraverso
un percorso completamente diverso uno
dall'altro
a sviluppare un
[Musica]
linguaggio che riesce a bloccare in un
qualche modo è a permeare la lauro dias
che vi siete posti di raggiungere quindi
la prima cosa è assolutamente questa
dopodiché
le opportunità che oggi come oggi ci
vengono offerte no fondamentalmente
dalla crisi climatica che sembra un
paradosso
no
sono legate al fatto che in questo
momento è arrivato il marketing cioè io
lo vedo nelle grandi aziende nelle
istituzioni nei musei aperti
no
sì questo è l'argomento questo è
l'argomento del momento cioè io parlo
spesso con persone che mi coinvolgono in
progetti che hanno un problema c'è dal
loro punto di vista no cioè arrivo le
dicono cavolo dobbiamo fare qualcosa
perché adesso quest'anno ci hanno
imposto un budget sulla sostenibilità ok
tu puoi prenderlo in due modi
greenwashing puoi parlare di tante cose
io la vedo come una forma di transizione
perché dal momento che non ci
continuiamo a parlare tra venti persone
che la cosa con lo scolo già molto bene
ma cerchiamo di
influenzare persone che le cose non la
conoscono minimamente che non gli è mai
interessata e che è che il primo dentro
no
delle delle stanze che che prima non era
possibile accedere
ecco io credo che come artisti li stiamo
facendo veramente influenza ok e quindi
questo apre anche per rispondere a un
terzo punto della tua domanda a
un'economia
sostenibile di scala ok cioè io i miei
progetti oggi non li scelgo
ricostruisco di progetto né avvalgo di
collaborazioni importanti per poterli
contestualizzare e validare dal punto di
vista scientifico
[Applauso]
giornalistico visivo eccetera eccetera
e i soldi li trovi da chi non qualcuno
in qualche modo oggi vuole appiccicarsi
sulla maglietta l'astag su stand hubble
ok
questo è un etica ovviamente a bordo
nella verifica di alcuni sforzi reali
che possono essere
versi in campo dalle aziende ma con le
goffaggini anche nel caso perché non
possiamo pretendere e questo è un punto
veramente importante che mondo cambi in
un secondo ok cioè siamo di mezzo la
transizione faremo mille errori
faremo i giganti si devono trasformare
le aziende che fanno mining devono fare
alluminio riciclato no
questo è veramente il cambiamento ok e
quindi
strutturare un progetto artistico su
queste tematiche
io credo che non sia mai stato già 15
anni fa quando iniziato a fare le prime
foto su queste cose qui
mangiavo a casa di mia madre
fondamentalmente quindi perché non avevo
i soldi per sostenermi oggi oggi devo
dire di no a molte cose quindi è io io
vorrei insomma trasferire un pensiero
positivo a chi si approccia
quindi siate voi stessi che poi alla
fine le cose troveranno il loro modo di
evolversi nella giusta direzione
[Musica]